- The people of Georgia are angry.
The people of the country are angry.
They're not taking this White House.
We're gonna fight like hell,
I'll tell you right now.
We will stop the steal.
- [Narrator] A week that
began with an extraordinary
phone call involving baseless
claims of voter fraud,
escalated to a pro-Trump
riot at the Capitol
that left five people dead
and culminated with numerous
administration resignations
and growing calls for
President Trump's removal
or resignation.
Here's a look at how the
historic week unfolded.
- [Donald] I won this election by hundreds
of thousands of votes.
There's no way I lost Georgia.
- [Narrator] In a Saturday
phone call President Trump urged
Georgia Secretary of
State, Brad Raffensperger,
to overturn the state's
November election results.
- [Donald] All I want to do is this:
I just want to find 11,780 votes,
which is one more than we have,
because we won the state
and flipping the state
is a great testament to our country.
- [Narrator] Raffensperger
and his general counsel
pushed back on the unfounded claims.
- [Brad] Well, Mr. President,
the challenge that you have
is the data you have is wrong.
- [Narrator] But President
Trump continued to double down.
- There's no way we lost
Georgia, there's no way.
That was a rigged election,
but we're still fighting it,
and you'll see what's going to happen.
We'll talk about it.
- [Narrator] At a Monday
rally ahead of Georgia's
Senate runoff elections,
the President repeated
the unfounded allegations and said
that Vice President Mike Pence
had the power to reject
electoral college votes
at a joint session of
Congress later that week.
- I hope that our great Vice President,
our great Vice President
comes through for us.
He's a great guy.
Plus, if he doesn't come through,
I won't like him quite as much.
- [Narrator] The pressure
play put the Vice President
in the spotlight, even
though legal experts said
he didn't have the authority
to reject state results.
- The future of the
country is on the ballot
here in Georgia today.
- Georgia voters have never had more power
than you have today.
- [Narrator] On Tuesday, as
Georgia voters went to the polls
to decide which party
would control the Senate,
the President tweeted and
retweeted claims of voter fraud,
which were flagged by Twitter as disputed.
- Democrat Raphael Warnock will unseat
Republican Senator Kelly Loeffler.
- Democrat Jon Ossoff will defeat
the Republican David Purdue.
- And both of those
Senate seats are flipping.
- This is at the feet of Donald J. Trump.
He basically saved
Chuck Schumer's chances.
- [Narrator] The victories gave Democrats
full control of Washington.
On Wednesday, President Trump promoted
and attended a save
America rally in Washington
that took place just
before Congress convened
to certify President-elect
Joe Biden's victory
in the November election.
- This is Donald Trump's Republican party.
- Let's have trial by combat.
- [Narrator] The rally
concluded with President Trump
encouraging his supporters
to March to the Capitol.
- We're going to walk
down Pennsylvania Avenue.
I love Pennsylvania Avenue.
And we're going to the Capitol.
We're going to try and
give our Republicans,
the weak ones, because the strong ones
don't need any of our help.
We're going to try and
give them the kind of pride
and boldness that they need
to take back our country.
- [Narrator] In the hours that followed,
rioters wearing pro-Trump
gear attacked police officers,
smashed windows and broke
into the Capitol building,
forcing lawmakers to seek cover
and temporarily halting
the democratic process
of certifying the electoral college votes.
Five people, including a
Capitol police officer,
died as a result of the unrest.
That afternoon, President Trump
posted a video on social media.
- It was a landslide election,
and everyone knows it,
especially the other side,
but you have to go home now.
We have to have peace.
- [Narrator] Some social media companies
removed the video and later
locked the President's accounts
citing violations of their policies.
- Criminal behavior will never dominate
the United States Congress.
This institution is resilient.
Our democratic republic is strong.
The American people deserve nothing less.
- [Narrator] Wednesday night
after the Capitol was clear,
Congress reconvened to
finish certifying the votes
and back in session, some Republicans
who had planned to object
to the certification,
had a change of heart.
- The events that have transpired today
have forced me to reconsider.
And I cannot now in good conscience
object to the certification
of these electors.
- The votes for president
of the United States
are as follows:
Joseph R Biden Jr. of
the state of Delaware
has received 306 votes.
Donald J. Trump of the state of Florida
has received 232 votes
- [Narrator] On Thursday,
several government officials
resigned, top democratic lawmakers called
for President Trump's removal,
and President-elect Biden
blamed President Trump
for Wednesday's events,
condemning the violence
- What we witnessed
yesterday was not descent.
It was not disorder.
It was not protest.
It was chaos.
They weren't protesters.
Don't dare call them protests.
They were a rightist
mob, insurrectionists,
domestic terrorists.
- [Narrator] Thursday
evening, President Trump
posted a new video online
addressing the nation.
- A new administration will be
inaugurated on January 20th.
My focus now turns to ensuring a smooth,
orderly and seamless transition of power.
This moment calls for
healing and reconciliation.
- [Narrator] He called the
storming of the U S Capitol
by a mob of his supporters,
a heinous attack,
but accepted no
responsibility for the riot.
Friday morning, President
Trump announced on Twitter
that he would not be
going to the inauguration
of President-elect Biden on January 20th.
By the afternoon, Democrats had drafted
an article of impeachment that they plan
to introduce Monday.
The White House pushed
back against the effort,
and in a statement said,
"A politically motivated impeachment
"against a president with 12
days remaining in his term
"will only serve to further
divide our great country".
Friday evening, Twitter
said it permanently banned
President Trump's Twitter account,
due to the risk of further
incitement of violence.
A tweet from president Trump's official
US government account
said Twitter employees
had coordinated with Democrats to try
and silence himself and his followers,
adding, "we will not be silenced".
Twitter removed the
tweets from its platform,
citing a policy violation.
Into the weekend, authorities
continued to make arrests
and seek information
about the perpetrators
of Wednesday's riot.